[Music]
you're a proponent of effective altruism
that sounds pretty good what is
effective altruism
so Peter Singer is known for as a
repellent of this and I really admire
Peter Singer I think that he's pretty
persuasive on this which is that though
I'm not a utilitarian and I don't agree
with him on a lot of other things I do
think that he's right that a lot of
people who are in rich countries have
the capacity to do an extraordinary
amount of good by donating to effective
charities and that is morally good if
they do and so the idea of effective
altruism has two parts the first is the
all tourism part that comes first which
is that it's morally good to give uh a
morally good if you're fortunate enough
to be able to to give and what they
recommend is ten percent of your income
and then if you are going to give once
you're like onboard with a view that
it's morally good to give to people to
you know promote well-being to promote
people's health well why why what where
should we be giving who should we give
to and you should give to the place
where your donation can do the most good
and so charities that I favor as an
effective ultra star the against malaria
foundation which mostly focuses on bed
nets mmm-hmm bed net distribution and
give directly which is cash transfers to
poor families in Kenya and Uganda yeah
how do you figure out who's using the
money properly you know you always hear
a story every now and again of
nonprofits that you think you're giving
all this money to them and that they're
gonna you know clean water or whatever
it is but then later you find out like
eighty percent of the money goes to
administrative costs or for them to
throw parties fundraisers to just get
more money to throw more parties or that
there's a great website give all calm
and give well has a team of researchers
but to try to evaluate which charities
they think are going to be the most
effective and they recommend both give
directly on the against malaria
foundation one nice thing about give
directly is that cash transfers are
pretty easy to administer you can just
do it over
mobile bank transfers and the give
directly team has a lot of people who do
really good follow-up to see what the
effects are so they can see kind of the
randomly assigned villages to get the
transfers and then they can see the
effect of having the trance cash
transfers as a poverty anti-poverty
intervention and it does look like cash
is like a very effective anti-poverty
intervention yeah is this also in effect
an argument for lowering taxes in
general that if people had more money in
their pocket perhaps 10% more they could
give 10% more to things that they really
cared about I think that there are lots
of good reasons to hurt absence because
I think that currently like some of what
the government does with taxes is like
not great you know for example or very
against war I don't know that this is
the best argument for that but that
generally if you had more money in your
pocket you might be willing to give more
money to causes that you really care
about I think people should be willing
to give to causes that they care about
whatever their tax rate is um and I
think that people should care about
causes that do the most good dollar for
dollar yeah so you're also writing a
book on sex worked yeah it's a foreign
against that wasn't a great segue yeah
yeah it's a foreign against book so it's
I'm the for decriminalization man and
I'm writing with a co-author Laurie
Watson and she's against
decriminalization yeah so what's the
argument against it at this point I mean
this is another place that I go very
much to the libertarian side which is
that if a woman a woman or a man or
whatever wants to take control they're
alive and be a prostitute or be involved
in sex work and it's an even exchange
they're doing something for money I have
no problem with any of this alright
coolest person I need to come there you
go alright I'm with you on this one so
who am i arguing again yeah there's a
lot of people so some people have a view
of like sort of sexual moralism that you
know there's certain norms that should
govern people's sexual choices that's
like a kind of more traditionalist
view I think that people who hold that
view aren't entitled to use the
government as a means to force everybody
else to live in accordance with it
there's a feminist argument people worry
that having sex work especially
pornography but sex work more generally
will contribute to the subordination and
objectification of all women by
promoting sexist ideas of female
subordination or views of women as
objects but to be clear sex work isn't
only about women I mean their planning
involved etcetera yeah but feminists
focus on the detrimental effects of the
sex industry for women as a whole right
often their arguments about occupational
health and safety related to the dangers
associated with the profession I don't
think that the profession is more
dangerous and being a commercial
fisherman right and aren't there studies
that show that like in in Amsterdam for
example that you know the women that are
involved in sex work are in unions and
that they've been able to bargain for a
better health care and things like that
to be sure I think about our ideal
that's policy that I favor is out of New
Zealand where it's just treated like all
other kinds of work but of course if
you're concerned about the risks the
occupational health and safety risks of
sex work you should be concerned by
black markets as well equally and black
markets are more dangerous so yeah
there's a kind of kind of traditionalist
argument there's a feminist argument
there's a kind of a labor argument a lot
of people worry that it's exploitative
by that they mean that if a person makes
a decision without having any acceptable
alternatives then though the decisions
not coerced it's not sufficiently
voluntary to merit respect mm-hmm
I think that that could apply to a lot
of work a lot of low-wage work
especially people only choose to take
those jobs at the waves the daheia
because they lack acceptable
alternatives I think that we should
therefore favor a basic income so I do
think that it's a problem that people
only choose certain types of jobs or to
work at all because they lack acceptable
alternatives and I can talk more about
why here a basic income yeah but I also
think that you know if you don't favor
basic income the voluntariness concerns
don't more in prohibition of sex works
if the problem is that people who are
choosing to work in an industry only
choose because they have very few
options I don't think that an acceptable
solution to that is to just
straightforwardly prohibit the few
options that they do have this parallels
arguments in international global
justice about sweatshops where it's like
like only choose to work in sweatshops
because they lack acceptable
alternatives I don't think the solution
would be to ban spot shops or to even
enforce regulations that would lead
sweatshops to go to another place right
then half the people screaming about it
or holding you know have iPhones in
their pockets you know yeah right I mean
it's just a fact and I think that you
know when people are concerned about
these types of labor issues sex work
sweatshops they are genuinely concerned
for the workers like I don't think that
there's a sort of bad faith there but I
would press those people to say like
well what is the alternative that goes
along with the bad I mean it's very easy
to say I don't approve of this
circumstance but I'm like what is your
solution you know I mean yeah like I
favorite basic income - but like the
only failing a basic income I don't
think that further eliminating the
options of people who are already
suffering for lack of options helps them
yeah so what would a basic income look
like to you I've done correctly well I
don't take a big stand on like how much
it should be why do I favor a basic
income you might think like oh you're
libertarian broadly like why have the
government redistribution pupils income
and that's what you were saying like oh
I'm against like a high tax it's like I
don't really have too much of opinion on
how high taxes would be necessarily per
se or like but I have more of an opinion
on what they spend it on um
public officials spend it on yeah well I
do agree it's mostly about spending and
I've got to cut the spending down and
then the government would just need to
take less from you if it would stop
overreaching on what it thinks it's
supposed to do yeah and so like I'm
against a lot of what public officials
spend the money that they tax people on
but taxes in particular I'm a little bit
more ambivalent about I mean I kind of
think given the political institutions
we have right now like no we should
we should oppose a kind of raising money
to go to war I mean that that's that'd
be bad because I think war is bad but
should we be in principle opposed to
taxes per se that's a little bit more
complicated so say that you're a broadly
kind of libertarian person a lot of
people will say that means that you know
nobody should violate another person's
natural rights but do people have
natural rights to not just their bodies
but external objects property out in the
world so one of my favorite philosophers
Michael humor kind of like an
anarcho-capitalist and he's like well at
least some stuff out in the world if you
build a hut like in the woods and like
you live there someone can't just like
roll in and like knock it down like you
have a natural property to that but some
other property rights are going to be
conventional some property rights are
going to exceed whatever natural rights
we have so like money that's a good
example that's a very conventional
system so now you have a government and
the government says okay here's the
property system that we're going to
enforce well one thing that property
system should do is it should respect
everybody's natural property rights and
natural rights to their own bodies
whatever that is mm-hmm but then the
government goes further and they're like
and also we're gonna enforce all of
these property conventions and we're
gonna use the coercive power of this
government that nobody consented to like
none of us signed up right to enforce
these kind of property conventions and
the thing about these property
conventions let's call them capitalism
is that they're gonna make people
generally better off but they're gonna
pick winners and losers are gonna make
some people worse off some people really
really badly off some people
fantastically well off so we have the
government that's enforcing you know
protections for people's natural rights
but also establishing these property
conventions how are the property
conventions enforced oh the property
conventions are enforced in part with
violence with coercion which is a threat
of violence against people's natural
rights their rights against being
threatened with violence and so I don't
think that you know I feeI don't favor
basic income as in like I deal with
theoretic solution I think ideally no
violence against anybody without their
consent but given that we have
governments which are using violence to
enforce laws and property conventions
against everybody without their consent
a basic income is a way of compensating
people for that injustice for the
injustice of the enforcement of a
coercive property system that forces
conventions which the enforcement of
which requires violating people's basic
rights yeah it's interesting cuz I've
heard a couple of different libertarian
arguments for basic income and on its
head if you were just looking at it you
would think that just makes no sense and
yet I I completely understand what
you're saying there
what is the inherent problem though that
once you set this income and I'm not
asking you for the number you're giving
everybody but once you set this that
just the way economics works I mean
you're just gonna increase the cost of
everything else for everybody right so
they've seen basic income studies and I
mean the evidence this week of course
like there's not been like a full-scale
like great you know ideal basic income
and forest but they're giving you a
basic water level thank you how are we
talked to death um but they're all still
be incentives to work and there will
still be positional goods and positional
advantages all of these that can come
sure do I think is give people the
freedom not to participate in the labor
economy right if they don't want to I
guess the thing that I struggle with is
that once you said it that you will
always have politicians coming in that
want more votes from the people that are
getting it and they're just always gonna
say raise it raise it raise it and that
every year that goes by we're just going
to raise it and raise it and raise it
and that will raise the cost of
everything else like if that to me is
the human part of it yeah that I
struggle with that it's just nature
every politician is gonna be like well
if I look at my district we have a lot
of people on it let's raise it I want
more votes yeah and so I don't think
that the basic income and this is true
of basic income advocates across the
political spectrum very few will ever
say the basic can compete should be
raised so high that it depresses the
total pie you know so like you wouldn't
like the basic game to be as high as it
can up until the point that it doesn't
you know swing over each in the other
direction right but is that just not the
way politics works I think
that's sort of what is the problem that
I get you I'm with you no I mean like I
completely understand that but just the
nature of the political system you're
gonna give them this this power to do
this and then always they will raise it
and whatever that threshold is that
you're talking about of course they're
gonna run over that yeah but that's
going to be true of whatever your kind
of political ideals are is that you're
always going to be have to have a
concern about these sorts of public
choice worries or like moral incentives
that are gonna cloud people's vision I'm
interested in like what does justice
require like what's the truth about what
justice requires and I think that a
mistake that libertarians often make is
that they they're sort of like question
begging and their arguments for having
property rights will just be like people
have rights to their property rights
without explaining why would where those
property rights came from and I think
that what justice requires does include
a respect for certain kinds of property
rights whatever the kind of natural
rights are but that often times the
enforcement of a property system far
exceeds that and so as a matter of
justice the basic income could be a form
of compensation for that initial
injustice so that's a very in principle
argument you're kind of asking like oh
but like in practice what did that like
right I'm just giving you the rubber
meets the road one like I get it at the
philosophical level for sure but then so
you might think like what's the point of
what's the point of this defense the
basic income it's like in practice it
wouldn't mm-hmm but you always have to
have some kind of ideals about what you
think is true about justice just to
ground like what are your kind of North
Stars for like what policies you
advocate for now and so like where the
rubber meets the road you might think
like is well now given that we have this
view how do we assess existing policies
here's one way to think about this being
informative think about cash transfers
as benchmarks for any kind of assistance
program so like I think that cash is a
more respectful way to help people
because it respects their authority to
decide how best to help themselves or
how to make choices that reflect their
own values and so you know whatever
intervention public officials want to
enforce on behalf of people in order to
help them out let's just hold it up to a
benchmark up
person benchmark of like how people
could have used used that money
individually if you just like sent them
that money as a check and like I think
that some programs will probably beat
that benchmark but just thinking in
terms of using a cash transfer as a
benchmark for evaluating the justice of
different things that public officials
use redistribute of Taxation to do
that's like one practical implication of
thinking about a basic income is being
required by justice yeah it's
interesting all right I want to finish
strong on critical thinking cuz it's a
phrase that I mention often on this show
that I think if we're lacking one thing
in this country more than any of those
it's critical thing and the ability to
think clearly look at a problem
understand your intellectual opponents
argument as opposed to just what you
think their argument is not impugn
everyone's motives I mean that's
basically what I've tried to do on the
show consistently for a couple of years
right now do you think we're like a
critical thinking disaster moment right
now like we don't see it we don't like
it just in the public course like well I
think in the public discourse maybe not
when you're with a lot of academics that
you're spending time with but I think
the general public discourse is really
lacks critical thinking it's like we've
picked our sides we're yelling at each
other all the time we're demonizing
constantly all of that we're not
thinking about issues really clearly and
critically more so than in the past do
you think I think partly the Internet
has has caused this you know the Twitter
a'f occation basically of everything and
the short way we think about things and
we go from one crisis to the next crisis
/ outraged about something one day and
then we forget about it the next day you
know even if you look at the the
shooting in Las Vegas it's about two
months ago you know I think 58 people
dead it seems like there's almost no
information about it like we just let it
go we just forget things which i think
is a part of critical thinking like we
just don't look at things sort of
holistically and and try to figure out
what really is true yeah I mean you
might fall into like a sort of
availability bias where like you see
people on the internet shouting at each
other and being
and make people kind of acting in bad
faith or be critical you're like oof
critical thinking worse than ever
then like look at the past where which I
think like the past was by and large was
a terrible place yeah yeah I'm not
saying it's worse than ever there's
something about it that fuels perhaps
because of the internet worse but
generally I just don't think we're in a
good state right now the critical
thinking but I mean what's your
counterfactual I mean cuz like like when
was it better yeah
and though you might look at the
internet now I would guess he would I
would say it would probably better
around our around the time of the
founding of the country that the
founding father is at least when they
were writing documents these were
principal documents that they were
having
you know Lincoln Douglas that's not
Founding times but in town a person
really critical thinker there yeah
absolutely
Thomas Jefferson is my favorite founder
what do you say about a person is your
favorite founder yeah what what do you
like about Thomas Jefferson I love
Thomas Jefferson
what do you again I mean his
understanding of Liberty and liberalism
and what the role of government should
be I mean interesting that he's like
writing Declaration of Independence
while he is owning slaves and you're
right he was it was bad like I was not
good if you're gonna make a favorite
founder I would not pick me George
Washington owned slaves - yeah and
didn't free them till his deathbed but
those are but that to me that just shows
that these were complex people of their
time yeah Thomas Jefferson you're right
he was writing the laws to free the
slaves while he owned slaves and I went
to his house in Monticello and they they
give a really I think very forthright
explanation of what his life was like
but I mean if you go to the Washington
Monument I was there just a couple weeks
ago and you really read the things that
he was writing about yeah he was a
flawed human but I mean there are things
that 50 years from now they're gonna
look back that we're probably saying
right that's exactly right yeah and I
think that is one of the values of
critical thinking is to try to look
around where we are now and be like okay
we know that in the past it was like a
moral catastrophe for women I've heard
people of color the past was such a bad
place and very likely in people who were
really trying
really trying to do good critical
thinking like pick your person I don't
know that would pick Thomas Jefferson
but he's not my favorite founder people
were really good faith people we're
making really big moral mistakes very
likely we are living through a kind of
moral catastrophe right now but we can't
see it and so the value of critical
thinking is to say like what is that
moral catastrophe that's in our midst
right now and I think that there are
some candidates that people are talking
about and then there are something that
we might not even be able to imagine now
is critical thinking especially bad now
because of the internet maybe but maybe
critical thinking is getting better
because of the Internet
I kind of think like how incredible that
I have access to so much of human
knowledge just like sitting in my office
right so many more arguments than I
would have seen before or like before
people sort of only knew the
perspectives of their own place and time
maybe what looks like at the critical
disaster thinking disaster is just that
people are exposed to all of these
different arguments and perspectives and
that in the past they weren't and so
like yes there's more conflict but
there's also potentially more progress
yeah on the same dimension hello I
didn't sort of like took a turn with
that answer but like when you mentioned
that there were products at that time
maybe we are living through a moral
catastrophe there's a nice paper about
moral catastrophe that I think it does
illustrate the value of maybe both
critical thinking and a sort of
epistemic quick humility like that sort
of like me here we're also really
getting it wrong in this way yeah maybe
we'll do a whole other show on the
founders together and intellectual
historian yeah that's just really
interesting to me and obviously we don't
have to end this in perfect agreement on
that but I think it's it's interesting
because to me Thomas Jefferson
everything I've ever written is his
thinking his thinking was perfectly
clear it doesn't mean that the person
yeah that he was was not flawed and by
yes by 2017 standards we know he was
having sex with a slave which in effect
is rape because he had the power over
her so I
get it and yet at the same time as I
said it was writing the laws to free
them was doing so much goodness for
people to own their lives and be
individuals and and have the country
that we have right now and I just think
it's yeah so that's why I love them but
then there were also like abolitionists
you know at the time and throughout
history who were getting it right and so
I mean I think one thing that I think
that when we think about I think he was
trying to nurture the system through a
horrible phase basically you know what I
mean like yes there were abolitionists
that were more openly abolitionists than
he was as he was part of the government
but he was also trying to not destroy
everything at once because there was a
lot of goodness in the system too yeah I
did not expect in this tell us more yeah
yeah what effect critical thinking it's
yeah maybe there's maybe there's an
internet piece of it that makes it sort
of better and worse at the same time
yeah I think that one thing that
sometimes happens in these sorts of
debates is a sort of like relativism
where people become like very suspicious
about like thinking about the moral
truth or like they're being immoral
truth and think like oh well true for
the time or true for that place or true
for that person and then there's like
this sort of like second stop where
people are like so like who's to say
like you know like we'll just have a
sort of like we should all just be
tolerant of everybody else's few points
and like we should we shouldn't like
cast judgment on people with whom we
disagree in any tense and I think that's
true that you should have a sort of
robust tolerance just for people
expressing different kinds of few points
but I also think that that doesn't mean
that there's not like a right answer and
like there definitely are right answers
they're just really hard for us to know
and like sometimes when people disagree
or when people on the internet or like
oh like being mean to each other because
people think like the that sort of cast
out on like anybody being right about
anything and you want
the person who says that like people
shouldn't be mean but like no like I
think that there's like a truth about
like the right and wrong answer about
these questions about moral questions
and political questions about justice
about what we should do but that part of
that right answer is that we should have
more tolerance that we should be
tolerant of different viewpoints but
that's that's something that's a moral
claim to like we shouldn't have like a
kind of I think we should resist we
should resist move to relativism from
the view that like we should be
respectful of disagreement you know like
I am completely different completely I'm
completely with you on that and I'm
always for more tolerance in the truest
sense of what tolerance is not not fake
dollar that we that we often see these
days I think we should since you're
already co-authoring a book where you're
taking one side and another side will do
the the co-authored Thomas Jefferson
book there you go I'm just planting it's
been a pleasure chatting with you and
for more on Jessica follow her on
Twitter it's at miss Jessica that's a
great how did you get that Twitter and
that's a good one and check out her book
pharmaceutical freedom
[Music]
you